>> Tucker: EXACTLY THE SORT OF
PERSON THE LEFT IS ALWAYS
TELLING YOU THEY DEFEND,
DEFENDED HIMSELF AGAINST AN
EARLY-MORNING BURGLARY BY FIRING
THREE WARNING SHOTS OF THE
BURGLARS, AND WOUNDED ONE OF
THEM, NOT FATALLY.
IN A SHOCKING INVERSION OF
JUSTICE, THAT MAN, THE IMMIGRANT
CLERK, IS UNDER HOUSE ARREST AND
THE BURGLAR, THE RINGLEADER OF
THE GROUP WHO BROKE AND HAS BEEN
CLEARED OF ALL CHARGES AND WALKS
FREE TONIGHT.
HOW DOES THAT WORK, EXACTLY?
HE OWNS THE ARLINGTON SMOKE SHOP
IN ARLINGTON, VIRGINIA, AND WE
ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM BACK ON
THE SHOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO, TO THE MOST SHOCKING PART
FIRST.
THE MAN WHO DEFENDED HIMSELF IS
UNDER HOUSE ARREST BUT THE
BURGLAR HAS BEEN LET OUT?
ARE YOU SURE?
>> I AM 100% SURE.
THIS IS SO SAD AND SO SHOCKING.
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING IN ARLINGTON, VIRGINIA.
WE WENT TO COURT ON JULY 30TH
AND FINALLY, WE SEE THE VIDEO.
I HOPE THAT ARLINGTON COUNTY
WILL SHARE THE VIDEO EXACTLY.
IT’S EDITED BY THE PROSECUTORS’
OFFICE BECAUSE THEY DO NOT PLAY
THE VOLUME.
THE REASON THEY DON’T PLAY THE
VOLUME IS THAT IT WAS SO VIOLENT
THAT THE VOLUME WILL BE ENOUGH
TO GET HIM OFF THE CHARGES.
SO WHAT HAPPENS, WE SAW THE
VIDEO, THREE MASKED MEN RUSHED
IN, AND HE EVEN SAID THEY ALL
HAD KNIVES, THEY ALL HAD
WEAPONS, THEY WERE PREPARED WITH
MASKS, GLOVES, AND WHEN THEY
APPROACH, HE EVEN SCREAMED A
WARNING BUT THEY DECIDE TO
IGNORE SO WHEN HE OPENED THE
BEDROOM DOOR, HE MISSED THE GUY
FACE-TO-FACE WITH THE MASK ON,
ALL BLACK.
HE ADMITS IT WAS PITCH BLACK.
THE CRIMINAL ADMITS IT WAS PITCH
BLACK AND AS SOON AS HE MET
FACE-TO-FACE, HE SHOOTS HIM,
CLOSES THE DOOR --
>> Tucker: GOOD.
>> BECAUSE THERE’S THREE PEOPLE
IN THERE.
CLOSES THE DOOR, PICKS UP THE
PHONE, CALLS THE POLICE, PICKS
UP THE PHONE, THE GUYS NOT ON
THE GROUND NO MORE.
THEY’RE RUNNING AROUND THE SHOP
SO HE SHOOTS TWO MORE TIMES
BECAUSE HE’S SCARED FOR HIS
LIFE, THIS NEVER HAPPENED TO HIM
BEFORE AND WHAT HAPPENS IS ONE
OF THE GUY DRAGS THE OTHER
CRIMINAL OUTSIDE.
THAT IS WHEN THE OFFICERS
ARRIVED AND THEY PUT HIM IN JAIL
AND IT’S VERY SAD.
AND I STILL CAN’T BELIEVE THAT
HE WOULD BE PROTECTED BY THE
PROSECUTORS AND THE PROSECUTOR’S
OFFICE IS VERY UPSET THAT I CAME
ON YOUR SHOW AND SPEAK THE
TRUTH, AND NOW THEY ARE LOOKING
AT THE WHOLE THING A DIFFERENT
WAY.
THEY WANT TO SHOW US SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THEY’RE
PROTECTING THE CRIMINAL.
I’M SURE IF THE CRIMINALS BROKE
INTO THEIR HOUSE, THEY WOULD BE
DOING TEN YEARS IN JAIL RIGHT
NOW, AND HE HAS A GPS ON HIM.
HE HAS TO PAY $350 OUT OF HIS
POCKET EVERY MONTH FOR THE GPS.
$800 CHILD SUPPORT FOR A GUY GUY
CANNOT TAKE HIS DAUGHTER TO THE
PARK WHILE THE CRIMINAL IS ON
SNAPCHAT RIGHT NOW, SMOKING A
JOINT CELEBRATING THAT HE IS
FREE AND THIS SAYS TO THE
COMMUNITY, JUVENILES OUT THERE,
YOU CAN GO ROB AND STEAL IN THE
PROSECUTOR WILL STAND NEXT TO
YOU AND DEFEND YOU AND PUT THE
REAL PEOPLE WHO WORK HARD, WHO
TRY TO LIVE THE AMERICAN DREAM
AND PUT THEM IN JAIL.
THIS IS VERY SAD.
THE PROSECUTOR HEARS THIS,
JOSHUA KATCHER, PLEASE, LOOK
DEEP INTO THIS CASE.
YOU HAVE KIDS, YOU UNDERSTAND.
I’M SURE IF THE CRIMINALS BROKE
INTO YOUR HOUSE, IT WOULD BE A
TOTAL DIFFERENT THING.
AND WE ARE ALSO STILL
STRUGGLING.
WE HAVE A COURT-APPOINTED
LAWYER, BUT WE DEFINITELY NEED
HELP OUT THERE, BECAUSE THIS IS
SAD FOR JUSTICE.
THIS IS INJUSTICE, REALLY?
>> Tucker: IT ENRAGES ME
HEARING THAT AND THE ARMED
ROBBER IS SMOKING WEED ON
SNAPCHAT.
HE’S SLEEPING IN THE STORE TO
PROTECT IT AND THEY BREAK,
THREATEN HIM WITH KNIVES,
DEFENDING YOURSELF IS NOW A
CRIME.
THE WHOLE THING IS SO GROTESQUE.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON
AND I HOPE YOU WILL KEEP US
POSTED ON WHAT HAPPENS, AND I
HOPE THE PROSECUTORS, WHO SHOULD
BE ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES, TURNED
BACK FROM THE COURSE THEY’VE